in a federal lawsuit a 68-year-old
librarian is accusing north carolina law
enforcement officers of using excessive
force against her during a traffic stop
body camera footage shows the officers
grabbing stephanie bottom by her hair
and throwing her to the ground after she
was stopped for speeding this was back
in may of 2019.
our lead national correspondent david
begno spoke with bottom who says she
feared for her life in this incident
david good morning to you
good morning to you stephanie bottom was
driving from georgia to north carolina
for her great aunt's funeral
when she was stopped for speeding and
failing to heed to officers blue lights
now the librarian says she was listening
to loud music really loud music
and she didn't realize that the police
were behind her in trying to stop her
here's what happened next and i want to
warn you the video is disturbing
there's stephanie bottom a librarian
then 66 years old and grandmother of
five
face down on the ground after being
dragged out of her car
her offenses according to police
speeding 10 miles over the speed limit
and not pulling over for officers in
salisbury north carolina
stephanie what do you think when that
officer grabbed you by the hair
and pulled you to the ground i was
shocked i was in fear
i was scared for my life i didn't know
whether they were going to shoot me
in this body camera footage released by
bottom's attorney
an officer tells bottom that three
police cars have been following her for
about 10 miles
they used spike strips to flatten her
tires and stop
tonight her i didn't know you guys was
chasing after me
i was listening to my music did you see
the police officers behind you with the
blue lights on
i saw them eventually when i did look up
you know i was like why are these
policemen you know
behind me this happened back in may 2019
on interstate 85 in salisbury north
carolina
pretty exciting chase here at the edge
of my seat baby
as police pursued one of the officers
sounded pretty excited
bottom's attorney ian mance says that
bottom was no threat
and law enforcement had an idea of that
they
also pull up alongside her and talk
amongst themselves
that this is an older black female she's
by herself
they later wrote an incident report
where they said that
when they pulled up alongside her she
held her hand up in a manner that
suggested she was not sure what was
going on
miss bottom's lawsuit alleges that after
the incident
the officers congratulated each other
and one even brags about grabbing
a handful of dreads
ms bottom is suing the three officers
who removed her from the vehicle
the sheriff of rowan county north
carolina and the city of salisbury for
using
excessive force she says they tore her
rotator cuff
[Applause]
i have a good feeling one of these
officers if not all of them is going to
watch this
what would you want to say to them you
hurt me
you can't hurt vulnerable people you
can't
force and brutalize innocent people
if i was guilty for not stopping right
away
or um speeding it did not call for
what you did to me and you need to be
held responsible
miss bottom pleaded guilty to failure to
heed to the blue lights
she was also initially charged with
speeding and resisting an officer
those charges were dismissed now we
reached out to the rowan county
sheriff's office
and the three responding officers we did
not hear back
the salisbury police department declined
to comment a spokeswoman for the city of
salisbury told us
it cannot comment on pending litigation
it did previously issue a statement
saying quote
the salisbury police department strives
for positive interactions
with our residents and visitors it's
hard to even say that with a straight
face david
i mean after the video that we looked at
those officers they still have a job on
that for us
i am so angry and so saddened by what i
just saw gail what was most surprising
to me was the attorney saying in the
incident report one of the officers says
i pulled up on the side of her
and she looks like she might not know
what's going on and that's an indication
that they had a heads up
before they ever ripped her out and
they're laughing at her they're laughing
at her
this is the thing guys black people are
not treated with humanity
in so many cases and that's why i'm so
sick of
it and i just don't know how many more
stories we have to see like this and
this
this is the thing this was in 2019 yeah
before all of the stories that we
that we now know the names think about
if they're were you going to say anthony
i was going to say
the thing that struck me was one of the
first things that david said that she
was
they believe she was going 10 miles an
hour over the speed limit that's it
that's what started this that's it
that's it that leads to this
think if there wasn't video of this
she'd be telling this story for the rest
of her life nobody would believe her
those cops are still working walking
knock on the window have a conversation
ask
what's going on ma'am all right david
and they'd come out with guns drawn too
that's the other thing
they did after they pulled it beside and
saw